la ayuda que recibe Ucrania de parte de
los países del g7 y muy de manera
particular de parte de Alemania que este
año preside el grupo no se limita
solamente a la cooperación política a la
ayuda económica o incluso al envío de
armamento también como quedó claro en
una reunión de los ministros de Justicia
del eje 7 realizada en Alemania esa
cooperación con Ucrania se extenderá a
la investigación de posibles crímenes de
guerra cometidos por las fuerzas
militares rusas como parte de su
invasión de Ucrania como explicaron los
ministros de Justicia que atendieron
esta reunión esa cooperación se
extenderá en primer lugar a la
recopilación de pruebas Más allá de
Ucrania en Ucrania ya Hay un
procedimiento en curso para recolectar
pruebas pero esas pruebas también pueden
recolectarse por ejemplo entre los
migrantes entre los refugiados que
dejaron uc instalaron por ejemplo en
países como Alemania en Alemania se
estima que alrededor de un millón de
refugiados ucranianos la cooperación
también se refiere a una posible
coordinación entre los diferentes países
del g7 en la recolección de pruebas se
espera que se genere un punto de
contacto en cada uno de los países para
evitar duplicación en la recolección de
información se trata sin duda de un
desafío muy importante de parte del g7
un desafío muy importante también de
parte de Alemania y es un desafío que
puede tardar un buen tiempo en la medida
que los diferentes países Ucrania en
particular pero también los países del
g7 trabajan conjuntamente en la búsqueda
de pruebas para identificar posibles
crímenes de guerra